venezuela se ha convertido en el amigo
feo de los países hispanoparlantes da
igual como esté tu país venezuela está
peor por eso a los medios de
comunicación les encanta mostrarnos
imágenes de caracas para hacernos sentir
que bueno pues tampoco estamos tan mal y
esa es la razón por la cual en visual
político llevamos tanto tiempo evitando
la tentación de hablar de este país pese
a que muchos de vosotros nos habéis
pedido que lo hagamos pensábamos que
como todos los medios hablan de
venezuela es imposible aportar algo
nuevo sin embargo hay una cosa que casi
nadie se ha molestado en explicar
todavía cómo han llegado hasta ahí que
ha tenido que hacer nicolás maduro para
convertir el país con más reservas de
petróleo del mundo en un lugar en plena
bancarrota hoy te lo vamos a explicar
el legado de chávez por si alguien no lo
sabe
hugo chávez fue el anterior presidente
de venezuela y padre de la revolución
bolivariana una de sus primeras
políticas fue el llamado sistema de
democratización del empleo que
implementó en la empresa pedevesa que es
la compañía estatal de venezuela
encargada de extraer el petróleo que
tiene este país que como hemos dicho es
mucho más abundante que el de arabia
saudita
una plantilla de pedevesa se ha
duplicado hasta llegar a los 115 mil
empleados desde que chávez llegó al
poder en sólo cuatro años la empresa más
grande de latinoamérica se había
multiplicado por cuatro sin embargo
venezuela seguía produciendo el mismo
número de barriles de petróleo que antes
es decir que esta ampliación de
plantilla no se debía a criterios
empresariales sino simplemente a un
intento por parte del gobierno de crear
más empleos en la administración pública
pasó tres cuartas de lo mismo el gasto
público se multiplicó por tres durante
el gobierno de hugo chávez eso significa
muchísimos más funcionarios y muchísimos
más programas de todo tipo
sin embargo los ingresos por la
exportación del petróleo justificaban
todo por eso es durante estos años
cuando venezuela pasa de tener un 60% de
población viviendo bajo el umbral de la
pobreza a tener solamente un 30 y aunque
hugo chávez se empeñan en decir que
había una conspiración de los países
occidentales por atacar a la revolución
bolivariana lo cierto es que nadie
rechazaba el petróleo de venezuela y
para muestra aquí expongo una cita de
nicolas sarkozy que por aquel entonces
era el presidente y conservador de
francia
me alegra el buen desarrollo del
escrutinio marcado por una fuerte
participación que atestigua una vez más
la vitalidad de la democracia y
venezuela sin embargo este tipo de
políticas unidas al famoso el propio
terminaron por hacer que venezuela
dependiera casi en su totalidad del
petróleo en 2012 el 95 por ciento de las
exportaciones de este país eran crudo a
esto hay que sumarle que como hemos
visto pedevesa tenía un coste muchísimo
mayor que el de cualquier otra petrolera
del mundo sin embargo siempre y cuando
el precio de mercado del barril fuera
superior al coste de extracción
venezuela seguía ingresando dinero pero
esperad un momento porque ahora viene la
parte mala en el año 2014 los precios
del petróleo caen en picado y el primer
país en notar los efectos es venezuela
las meteduras de pata de nicolás maduro
para cuando empieza esta crisis
petrolera hugo chávez ya había muerto y
había sucedido nicolás maduro de si tú
si lo hay o silbo entonces
clarito me veo raro no sirvo un ratico
me dio una vuelta y se fue yo sentí el
espíritu del lo sentía y como dando una
bendición madura se encuentra con que
venezuela ya no gana dinero con su
petróleo sin embargo todavía tiene
muchos sueldos que pagar eso unido a la
política del pp propio se hace que
venezuela casi no tenga empresas
privadas con lo cual aunque quisiera
subir los impuestos y recaudar no podría
porque quién iba a pagarlos por si esto
fuera poco los impuestos se cobran en
bolívares que es una moneda que cada vez
vale menos es decir el gobierno no tenía
ni dinero ni capacidad de conseguirlo y
en ese momento es cuando maduro toma una
de las peores decisiones que puede tomar
un político imprimir dinero para
conseguir liquidar
al devaluar el bolívar la inflación se
disparó para que os hagáis una idea en
los tres meses de verano de 2015 los
precios se duplicaron esto significa que
si tú estás en caracas en el mes de
junio de 2015 y te tomas una cerveza que
te cuesta 50 bolívares vuelves tres
meses más tarde al mismo bar y la misma
cerveza te cuesta 100 pues esto es lo
que está pasando en venezuela desde hace
3 años
lógicamente todo esto dio al traste con
todas las misiones bolivarianas que
había creado hugo chávez para acabar con
la pobreza y en este momento es cuando
nicolás maduró toma la decisión que
termina por reventar toda la economía
venezolana nuevo instrumento legal para
regularizar toda esa actividad económica
pero tiene que ver con la creación del
precio máximo de venta al público
en opinión de maduro la inflación se
debía a la especulación de los
capitalistas olvidaba que su gobierno
había sido el primero en especular con
su divisa y cuál ha sido el resultado os
preguntareis imaginar que tenéis una
carnicería en maracaibo y vuestro
proveedor está en colombia y os vende la
carne en dólares vamos a poner por
ejemplo que el kilo de ternera está a 10
dólares el tipo de cambio que te da el
banco central de venezuela es de 10
bolívares por dólares pero en realidad
nadie te va a dar dólares a ese precio
así que si quieres pagarle a tu
proveedor a lo mejor le tienes que dar
el equivalente a 10 mil bolívares
una vez has comprado la carne llegas a
tu tienda en maracaibo y la quieres
vender pero a el gobierno pone un
control de precios y no puedes vender
más caro de 1000 bolívares con lo cual
no es ya que no ganes beneficio es que
estás en perdidas que haces en este caso
pues o una de dos o cierras la
carnicería o intentas colocar tu
producto en el mercado negro
y algunos preguntaréis y por qué tienen
que comprar productos en el extranjero
siguiendo mi ejemplo acaso no hay
ganaderos en venezuela la respuesta es
que cualquier producto que quieras
comprar necesita alguna herramienta o
alguna materia prima que se hace en el
extranjero por ejemplo si quisieras
producir su propio trigo en venezuela'
necesitarás las semillas los
fertilizantes el tractor algunas de esas
cosas seguro que está hecha en otro país
a día de hoy ningún país es capaz de
producir todo lo que consume todos de
una forma u otra
necesitan comerciar con otros países y
más aún venezuela que como hemos dicho
basaba toda su economía en un único
producto que era el petróleo y ahora ni
siquiera esto
venezuela ha lanzado su mayor oferta de
compra quieren comprar más de 8 millones
de barriles de crudo a eeuu o nigeria
como decíamos antes los costes de
producción de petróleo en venezuela son
tan altos que les resulta más rentable
comprarlo a otros países que producirlo
en el suyo y todo esto es lo que explica
estas colas kilométricas que vemos en
los supermercados de caracas donde la
gente se pega por un rollo de papel
higiénico
y ahora me toca preguntaros creéis que
maduro es capaz de sacar al país de la
crisis en la que él mismo le ha metido
existe alguna alternativa política real
en venezuela que nos pueda dar algo de
esperanza me podéis dejar vuestras
opiniones en los comentarios como
siempre si alguien quiere profundizar
más en este tema encontrará varios links
en la descripción si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a light y suscribiros al
canal si no lo habéis hecho todavía un
saludo y hasta pronto